What is up
Fellow squad fams.
It is I
your leader
coming at you with an update
*loud* UPDATE VLOG *noise*
I should have written a script for this video
*laughs*
I just felt like it's been a while since we've talked face-to-face
sincere
Down-to-earth honest discussion, which is why I'm talking normally. This is my normal voice
This is how I greet and talk to everyone. I really just wanted to say thank you things have been going well lately I am..
I'm really enjoying seeing the outcome of how you guys enjoy the videos reading all the comments
uh..
Loving all the support on the South Park series it really brings me back to have a let's play on the series finally
I've said it before but I
I really just wait for games that I know that you guys are gonna like and that I'm gonna like and it takes time
Obviously a lot of times
But once they hit it really feels like a special thing, so I really appreciate that you guys join the daily
Journey of those it's a lot of fun, so I just wanted to say thank you
I'm so glad I missed the whole like, "uh come on we need another one!" seeing that kind of thing in the comments
It's always fun. You know that's really how I fell in love with YouTube was because I watched Let's Plays
I watched daily Let's Plays really terrible Let's Plays, but still just the
Concept of everyday, you know you have a series to watch
Was such a fun thing and I love the fact that I can bring that to my audience again
You know despite all this time. I do make daily videos as normal
uh
Nothing has really changed there, but I feel like I finally figured out this new formula when I changed to this office
I changed my style of videos completely, you know.
Some of it may have been lost but some of it was gained as well
and I love the weekly videos that I do with the fan interaction PewDiePie submission ala reddit bullshit and
"You laught you lose", and me just ranting about stuff.
I finally feel like I figured it out
You know I figured out a series of videos that I can keep up and that feels fresh
And that's fun to me to record I can do all these things in a way that I don't have to get gray hair
Ironically my hair is white so I don't
You get the point!
another thing that I'm super grateful for is that..
You guys are buying my merch
*laughs*
Merch for me is always like yeah, okay?
Yeah, I make money out of it obviously but I'm so happy that you guys are just interested
In the stuff that I put out
It's a it's a very humbling thing that someone chooses to support you you know publicly by wearing something that represents me
I think, I think that makes me really really proud and I think probably for the first time PewDiePie as a brand that
You probably would at least wear in public without getting punched in the face.
part of the proceeds from the represent shirts
uh
Goes to Save the Children as well and so far
We've got twenty thousand dollars, in the name of squad fam, and that's a great thing
I really appreciate that we also have the meatball merch
Which of course is the greatest merch ever because I designed that merch my god
Can we get a picture?
look at that man
Swedish 10/10
Perfection he's like a good spaghetti meatball
except it's swedish meatball
We also have the chair, which I designed myself
It's kind of expensive for a chair, but for what you get with it?
My God!
this chair has changed my life
Okeh
Okay, also if you get one now you get the meatball shirt, how about..
THAT?
now it sounds like I'm just trying to sell you a bunch of stuff.. Don't
Maybe a little bit. I'm gonna be honest. Maybe a little bit, but mainly I want to say namaste
Which means apparently "nice to meet you"?
But I mean it in the context of thank you
*Thank you* in Swedish
It is kind of you!
That you bought some shirts...
other than that I'm looking forward to keep doing more videos
Which it feels like a great thing to say
sometimes the whole process of making
Videos can come and go in waves sometimes you're not bad into it. Maybe you're having a bad day
You don't feel creative and you're like. I don't know what to do, but regardless
I appreciate you guys it means a lot. I love you
I'm gonna end it here, and I think that's a good time to end it and
Just remember..
"Never grill..
.., Without a nice frill" (-_-)
57 million Subscribers Really
OK!
Thanks For leaving A Like
Squad Fam!
* Shoots CHRISTIAN Laser *
And BroFist..